do you work out in general I used to I
should be no like powerlifting and
everything dude I used to be jacked back
in the day really I was that animal do
you know it's [ __ ] we're on them
stable protein powder under my steroids
on steroids for a while when I was young
really yeah you aren't serious dosterone
something yeah you started to run a
stack just to get jack yeah I was like a
southern stack it was like testosterone
and like Crisco or something contesting
gravy daddy ball and [ __ ] Jack at one
point I couldn't use q-tips in my ears
because I couldn't get my really yeah is
there pictures online of this I don't
know there might be [ __ ] find that
chin it might be I'm just doing it just
for just to try it out or what I mean if
you want to really know when I really
think back and what I was doing
yeah I'd love that I was just how old we
first of all yeah I was let me see
17 or 18 nope it was after that that's
when I got involved in this damn cult
[ __ ] a real poll are you not on set
there that's out and Reseda dude what
are you doing huh why are you doing for
the Lord brother what do you think I was
doing same thing you probably were but
around black people things happen bro
well it looks like you're in like Africa
there Bobby I used to Santa Clarita and
you were just trying to blend in just an
adult yeah dude it's uh rural it gets
pretty long enough to kiss the sweats
you know long enough to put a warp zone
in your spirit I was out there dude
eatin [ __ ] dolphin dandruff doing dope
out there boy playing Color Me Mine with
my own body living out there boy making
pottery out of my dick
but I'll tell you this man what are we
talking about
Oh steroids what steroids before you
wearing a cold
yeah man I'm doing dick that's the dark
arts brought in and I've been in the
dark on some dark place he is there bro
but I never been in a fire on last year
lasted this one [ __ ] but yeah I used
to use them at enhancing drugs and I'll
used and the only thing I was really
getting performance enhanced for was
really the 11th grade when you see my
back rip I pull myself up like a champ
like a champ thirty times fast
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gift it's a gift
it's a gift